wir gehen erst zu paul ronzheimer in das
kriegsgebiet wieder das sind auch
dramatische stunden für dich paul ich
habe dich heute morgen auch gesehen den
tränen nah uns alle geht es jetzt in
diesem moment so wenn wir mila gerade
gehört haben dass uns zunächst in dein
herz schauen
sind ein mit wie man diese worte von mir
gehört sie hat vollkommen recht mit
allem was sie sagt die politiker haben
diesen menschen erzählt dass man putin
bloß nicht provozieren dürfte dass man
keine waffen liefern darf deshalb dass
es gut ist zu verhandeln und das nur das
am ende zum erfolg wird und wir sehen
die bomben wir sehen die flugzeuge wir
sehen die toten und das ist auch das
ergebnis oder es ist das ergebnis
westlicher politik wenn ich in diesen
stunden ich bin unterwegs immer noch in
der ost ukraine auf kleinen dorf wegen
um hier irgendwie durchzukommen denn man
weiß nicht an welcher stelle schon
russische panzer russische flieger sind
und wo wir dann nicht mehr durchkommen
würden wir wollen in die hauptstadt wo
sich möglicherweise der große krieg
anbahnt nämlich um diese hauptstadt und
ich haben telefoniert mit vitali
klitschko mit dem bürgermeister von kiew
so nervös habe ich ihn selten gesehen
gleichzeitig kümmert er sich weiter um
seine stadt wieder angesprochen um die
evakuierung um die bunker ja du hast
mein herz angesprochen ich weiß nicht
ich fühle mich völlig leer und dem was
ich hier in den letzten stunden gehört
gesehen und erlebt habe und ja
schockiert
jetzt wird dieser krieg vor allem jahr
so wahnsinnig fassbar so wahnsinnig
nadig das was wir von mila haaren durch
das was wir auch von dir hören dass
durch das was wir von den menschen hören
man fühlt sich vor allem hier in diesem
studio ganz weit weg und dann hört man
euch sprechen über diesen krieg schilder
uns ein bisschen das was du beobachtet
hat in den letzten tagen in den letzten
stunden über das was dort passiert
ja patricia gestern waren wir noch an
der front bei ludmilla einer alten frau
die dort erlebt hat wie der graf schuss
wie der mörserbeschuss über ihr haus
ging und die wände gewackelt haben und
sie immer dann in diesem keller
geflüchtet ist im gegensatz zu mir hatte
sie keine schutzweste keinen helm die
menschen haben keine schutzkleidung es
sind oft auch eher ärmliche verhältnisse
gerade in der ost ukraine
das ist kein reiches land und die
ukraine ist ein armes land und sie saß
dort mehrere stunden und hat darüber
nachgedacht und besprochen was dort
gerade passiert und hat immer wieder
verzweifelt zu mir gesagt wir passen
doch keine wussten was erzählt putin
das passiert kein genozid an russen von
ukraine begreifen russland sich an wie
kann es sein dass diese lügen in
russland geglaubt werden wie kann das
sein hat sie mich immer wieder gefragt
sie selbst hat zwei kinder in russland
leben lasst uns einmal ganz kurz schauen
wir sprechen gleich mit ihr weiter es
gibt im moment auch entwicklung hier in
deutschland die eurofighter werden oder
in stellung gebracht haben dort gerade
ab in neuburg an der donau vielleicht
wollt ihr uns das bild einmal zeigen das
sind bilder von dort also als bayern
dort von dem fliegerhorst neuburg an der
donau also dort im moment bewegung bei
den eurofightern man bringt sich
offenbar in kampfbereitschaft
dort verlegt richtung osten weiter dass
im moment bilder paul das wollten wir
zeigen dass hier eben jetzt auch endlich
bewegung drin ist dass die nato ihre
bereitschaft noch mal erhöht hat in
diesen stunden das wollten wir ihnen
kurz zeigen und gehen weiter wieder zu
paul dort in das auto in der ost ukraine
unterwegs du hast das gerade von
ludmilla erzählt die du gestern
getroffen hast
ja und diese verlegung die wir dort
gerade gesehen haben die hilft ludmilla
und den vielen menschen in der ukraine
nicht denn sie sind nicht teil der nato
warum sind sie nicht teil der nato bei
2008 deutschland und frankreich das
verhindert haben sonst müsste man sagen
gäbe es diesen krieg wahrscheinlich
nicht denn ein nato-mitglied anzugreifen
das wäre eine andere sache deshalb diese
frustration in den letzten jahren
seitdem ich in der ukraine
immer wieder kam die mahnung dass mehr
gemacht werden muss dass es mehr
sanktionen geben muss schärferer
sanktionen und auch jetzt wieder sagen
mir bei ihm wie kann das eigentlich sein
da bombardiert putin los er ist gibt
tote wir sehen die die helikopter am
himmel und gleichzeitig braucht ihr
immer noch mit euren sanktionen und sie
sind nicht habt ihr schmeißt zb brust da
nicht raus aus dem zahlungsverkehr swift
warum macht ihr das nicht aber ihr
selbst weiter verdienen wollt das ist
das was man hier von den ukrainern hört
verzweifelung dass selbst im zustand des
krieges es zwar laute stimmen gibt
empörung gibt olaf scholz sich äußert
andere politiker sich äußern aber die
taten an den taten messen die ukraine
uns deutsche und da kommt zu wenig muss
man diesen stunden sagen dass die
ukraine eigentlich von uns im westen
bereits geopfert bereits aufgegeben ist
ja natürlich ist das so kalt deutschland
hat die ukraine aufgegeben und zwar
schon seit langer zeit und strack
zimmermann hat das in einem tweet einmal
relativ offen und aus meiner sicht
zynisch gesagt wird gesagt ja aber wie
man jetzt waffen liefern würde das würde
ja auch nichts gegen putins übermacht
zeigen und das ist etwas was natürlich
in der ukraine ankommt wie müller das
gesagt hat wie unterlassene
hilfeleistung
schreib uns einmal wie es jetzt für dich
weiter geht welchen weg du jetzt nehmen
wirst und
ihr habt das aus kann hier mit dem auto
und so sieht das dorf die momentan aus
wo wir sind man sieht nicht überall
etwas vom krieg auch nicht überall
truppen was man sieht ist dass viele
viele menschen in diese richtung fahren
diese kleinen strafen hoch und busse
also das sind alles autos die wir auch
schon auf dem weg getroffen haben da
hinten weiter da hinten sieht man die
wunderschöne ukrainische flagge
eigentlich ein schöner tag heute
auch in diesem dorf und man sieht hier
menschen die noch auf der straße laufen
aber jederzeit kann jederzeit patricia
könnten auch hier russische panzer
einrollen so wie wir das jetzt schon ein
tier verleben wieder frieden hier
vermeintlich herrscht da drückt
kannst du aktuell dort ab sehen wo sich
im moment truppen befinden oder ist das
überhaupt nicht durchschaubar im moment
für dich es ist kaum durchschaubar wir
wussten dass in kharkiv zum beispiel
truppen aufmärsche waren die wir von
weitem gesehen haben heute morgen haben
wir aus dem bett durch lautes donnern
geröll durch die waffen die dort
eingesetzt wurden und ja jetzt versuchen
wir hier unseren weg uns durchzuschlagen
irgendwie nach ihr und am besten nicht
auf russische panzer zu treffen paul
ronzheimer für uns unterwegs in der
ukraine ist jetzt auf dem weg vom osten
des landes in die hauptstadt kiew danke
dir paul